na ja heute etwas schreckliches passiert
wie soll ich sagen diese wirklich
herzzerreißend und katastrophalen
nachrichten die ich jetzt mitteilen wäre
drehen und sich um katja erinnert euch
noch ein katana das ist dieser ein
youtube dies immer noch nicht geschafft
hat pornodarstellerin zu werden und zwar
aber ich lasse es zu recherchezwecken
auf ihrem instagram account es lässt
mich jetzt echt nicht gut aus und da
habe ich das hier gesehen
die bringt 19 verletzte habe ich mir
gedacht eigentlich ist es langweilig
jetzt ein ganzes video nun dieses sommer
ankündigung zu machen und deswegen
machen wir heute eine twilight stars dem
titel schon gesehen und leute die strafe
könnte härter nicht sein wenn ich es im
heutigen video verpacke und drei mal
lachen muss ich katjas neuen songs
vorbestellen
ihr merkt leute ich riskiere gerade hier
wirklich mein leben deswegen werden alle
millionen likes man brauche also lasst
es nicht zu lang werden scheitert aber
wenn ich drei mal acht wird dass katja
album mit beweist in diesem video noch
vorgestellt das video ist wir mal einen
youtube kaka von galil links und in der
beschreibung und villingen es los
diese vier kontakten sind heute abend
als team gekommen um eine ganze menge
service mit einem presslufthammer in die
eier zu schlagen bis das sperma aus dem
schwanz stresst und mann ins krankenhaus
muss dabei steht in marseille davis
gnadenlos im weg
schönes zusammen herzlich willkommen bei
gefragt verarscht in der tat haben sich
wieder viel spaß gefunden die der
meinung sind ausländer raus verteilt
natürlich können sie wieder fast
getroffen wir sind damals länder das
alles mein name ist regina ich kenne
mich mit falafel aus mein name ist
ullmann ich mache eine ausbildung zur
wollen in meiner freizeit statt sich
unheimlich gerne wenn eine stadt heute
muss ich wohl sitzen
ich war rückläufig war in 51 jahre alt
und komme aus bonn wo man sagt von mir
mega dass man wissen genauso groß sein
wie mein kopf also zum 22 das ist unser
team des heutigen abends jedes einzelne
mitglied vergleich zunächst zu mir
kommen und hänsel und gretel mit der
faust ins gesicht schlagen um möglichst
viel spielgeld für die teamkasse
erspielen um dann mit diesem spiel geld
in eine kettensäge duell jeweils zu
gehen gegen den negativ erlebt ich habe
viel zu reben die gefahr dass die leute
ich stelle mir diese scheiße jedes mal
vor hänsel und gretel schlagen und dann
in einen kettensägen duell mit dem [ __ ]
zu gehen wer von euch hat noch nicht
gemacht
automatisch nach hause beginnen wird
heute regina alina
[Applaus]
du bist ja auch über liköre experte
setzte sämtliche bären die wir im garten
haben da macht es jetzt mich überhaupt
nicht leute ich hasse diese videos ich
hasse diese videos das bild hin dass mit
diesen videos zu machen weil ich einfach
diesen ich weis machen heute abend ist
nun gar nicht so sehr dieses kein
youtube die kacke denken dann dieses
gestörte aber hast du eine vorliebe ich
freue mich sagen du bist ein charmanter
mann hier kommt neben den kommentaren
also sondern die bitte lasst es nicht
ziel kommt schon wenn ich nicht laut
lachen sie jetzt nicht okay ihr habt ihr
im video ticker abbekommen das nicht
schön sie zu sehen wie schön sie zu
sehen
wir wollen spiel regina dadurch deinen
scheiß geht am anfang erklären wir es
noch mal ganz kurz
aber du weißt eh bescheid wer es regen
erklären was überhaupt nicht und wie
locken sie was sollten säuglinge im
ersten lebensjahr nicht zu sich nehmen
bolzenschussgerät buttermilch ck3 was
ist die richtige antwort ich dir richtig
was sagt der ernährungsphysiologie aber
die können kinder noch habe ich
vertrauen und können dadurch
magenkrämpfe oder magenkrämpfe und auch
mediziner nächste frage
was sind melonen melonen b melonen oder
c kartoffel kroketten das ist dass ich
eine gute frage oder können wir um eine
kurze schauer
was haben wir haben was haben wir ich
hab genommen melonen lol was ist die
richtige antwort
daher ist jetzt ein bisschen näher dran
wir sollten jetzt mal ja bis breit ja
dann kommt jetzt die erste frage auf die
du richtig antworten wirst du [ __ ]
nürnberg da sollte man kann das wirklich
ohne wenn sozusagen nur anschauen und es
ist so es ist schon witzig aber muss ich
nicht so wegschmeißen
es ist die erste frage die du richtig
beantworten wirst du [ __ ] zwei von drei
haben wir jetzt schon bekannt
wie heißt die sympathische dampflok im
musical starlight express a dirty bit
spastizität schmuck
so ist und nun ich glaube dass sich das
müsst ihr sein ersatz nicht glaubt dass
die endet es hier mit b1 im finale mit
1500 euro was ist die richtige antwort
[Musik]
hier kommt die erste frage was hat eine
damals spur von etwa sechs kilometern
länge compact coupé kernreaktor c micro
compact kopf drin und brauchen dafür den
ersten paar stritt er würde uns gut
passen
was ist die richtige antwort
[Musik]
www kartoffel cricket baby darin zu
suchen statt kartoffeln punkte
du bist du ein priester aber okay gut
wetter gemacht heute war the change
kochten über durchgezogen amazon.de aber
ich bin ein ehrenmann ich glaube das ist
dicke lippen obwohl gott dicke lippen
katja ist es schon was habe ich getan
leute das war's von diesem video ich
gebe mich jetzt im sand vergraben wer
hier den einen oder anderen steine auch
nicht werfen wollen wegen dieser schande
wenn ihr mich seht klar gerne hier
gezogene neuer folge fast geht für euch
leute da bist ein video in dem ich auch
bin in dem ich nicht des euro wollt ihr
euch das ja schauen